hey dr. Burke here in this short video
we're gonna tell you about another tip
the fastest strategy to lose your belly
now a strategy is an higher-level
thing that you do to get some advantage
over things you have to realize this one
point that belly fat is not a weight
problem it's a hormone problem it's a
high cortisol problem so the diets that
don't diets don't work for this why
because diets don't lower cortisol they
lower calories so they create stress
because belly fat is held there for a
survival mechanism so in other words one
of the purposes of body holding fat in
your belly is to protect you against
starvation now what starvation that's a
diet every time you deprive yourself of
food and you lower your calories too
much this will not help the cortisol the
other thing you want to be careful about
is not to eat exercise too much so you'd
want to do long walks because exercise
is a type of stress that can aggravate
the belly there's people I knew that you
do boot camps and they actually add more
stress and they gain more weight from
overtraining okay so don't diet don't
exercise now what do we have to do we
have to do something to lower cortisol
cortisol is a hormone from the adrenals
that is jacked up way too high it's an
overactive gland so we want to realize
that the gland is triggered by all
stresses probably the biggest dress that
you probably know about is other people
like at work or family whatever so you
want to start to avoid stressful people
why because they will aggravate the
adrenals so I know it's hard to live in
a bubble but try to minimize the amount
of exposure you have on those stressful
personalities if possible but if you're
in a relationship or your boss it is
difficult I know that but the more
stress that you have with people you
have to counter it by doing things that
are anti stress like sleeping you have
to sleep longer but I know a lot of you
can't
so I recommend two things for sleep we
use adrenal formula fatigue formula
right before bed it'll put you out
you'll sleep there's no side effects
there's no drugs or anything
Drina before bed and then acupressure we
use acupressure either in the clinic or
we can do it you can do it on yourself
we show you how to do that but
acupressure it literally will pull
stress out of your body and help you
sleep it's one of the most effective
things to lower the stress level in the
body so those are the kind of the to
notice I said strategy I didn't say all
the little tiny details you just need a
higher strap level strategy versus what
everyone else does is going on a diet
trying to exercise it off or burn more
calories that is the wrong strategy okay
hope that helped I'll see you the next
one